[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
wow thank you the moment dude this is
the moment capture the moment the moment
is here we did it boys we did thanks for
coming man all those years of us working
on this podcast
yes thank you moment
laughs
made it happen the Matt and Shane secret
podcast live show took place last
Wednesday and it [ __ ] ruled dude they
had on special guest Michael Che Shane
was crushing Bud Lights the whole show
the live audience was great Matt was
coming in hot all night long all that
more is coming up in this week's episode
of the joke World comedy update but real
quick before we get started here please
do me a favor and just move your mouse
over that subscribe button real quick
click on that bad boy and boom you've
done it you've destroying the fastest
growing community in all of Comedy
congratulations welcome to joke World
make yourself at home stay a while hell
leave a comment December 14th is when
the Matt and Shane live show officially
began it took place in front of a sold
out audience at Chelsea Music Hall in
New York City and featured special guest
Michael Che although halfway through the
show Shane did mention that they were
trying to get Beetlejuice to be the
special guest but just couldn't get in
touch with them honestly the other guest
we were trying to get we were trying to
get Michael Chi and Beetlejuice
we couldn't get Beetlejuice we offered
him a hefty sum we couldn't get him wait
a minute he was gonna pay him a lot
you're not [ __ ] paying me okay
[Laughter]
every time my age-old conversation no no
no
honestly
just talking to the mic
this is how slaver got started we're
gonna pay you just pick it first we'll
get the money you think they went like
you're on the ground floor of a
brilliant startup it's a brand new
country
Mansion secret podcast is the perfect
example of why these live shows are
becoming so popular for Comedians and
fans because if they tried to upload
this episode just to normal YouTube it
would get taken down almost immediately
and they're not showing heavy segments
like ymh stuff it's literally just the
jokes YouTube could not handle that
pretty much every topic they brought up
any normal streaming service would
probably find an issue with but I
promise if you have a decent sense of
humor even an okay sense of humor just
slightly below average sense of humor
you'll find the show hilarious some
highlights that stick out to me right
off the bat was Matt and Michael Che
meeting live on the podcast for the
first time Michael's a kind of straight
lace character and Matt we all know him
and his Antics so him just dealing with
that realizing what a character Matt
mccuster is live on the podcast in front
of all of us watching him process that
that was pretty funny also the crowd
trying to convince Shane to call Kanye
West live on the show that was pretty
crazy for those of you that don't know
yay reached out to Shane a few weeks ago
for a potential interview I hate to
spill the beans but I gotta text
that said yo it's yay
and Kanye contacted me
that day that day he was yeah tomorrow
night yes and he wanted to work on
something on his media daily storm and
unfortunately I had to decline what yeah
yeah he should be here eating birthday
cake you want the views we could do that
but I do feel like the people that are
yeah latching onto them are taking
advantage of whatever's going on yeah
and that that looks [ __ ] lame yeah
it's Sinister because yeah he's the best
well that's yeah that kind of sucks
because I want to give my views on
Israel right now if you don't mind see I
already feel weird about talking about
it and it's funny it's a funny thing to
have him I mean it was crazy it gave me
like my face got hot I was in an Uber I
was talking to Matt and I was like dude
yay just texted me that's crazy did you
show that to the guy next to you I was
in the back of an Uber just like
like
he wants to talk right now it's like I'm
I'm in an airport I can't
time I was like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
cause I knew whatever he said I was
gonna say yes I [ __ ] love Kanye West
I love his music
there was also a live chat feature so
fans could talk to each other during the
show which I thought was pretty neat but
something that caught my eye afterwards
is Matt actually hopped into the chat
and said dude thanks again sorry if we
let anyone down y'all are the best
Shane's freaking out right now send him
your love I don't know what the hell
he's talking about I think everyone that
tuned into this can agree it was pretty
fantastic if you missed out last week
and still want to experience an hour and
40 minutes of completely Unchained
comedy you can still have access to the
show for two more days well you can
still buy access to the show for two
more days I should say over at
momenhouse.com Matt and Shane secret
podcast the bad friends live tour is
getting ready to kick off at the
beginning of next year with Bobby Lee
Andrew centino juicy jet ski Johnson and
the rest of the bad friends gang
embarking on a nationwide theater tour
starting in February it's always really
cool to see Santino and Bobby Lee
sharing a stage together especially for
big fans of the podcast who get a mix of
bad friends banter along with world
class stand up it makes for a pretty hot
ticket can I go back to the the black
eye
are you asking me to go back to the
block I just want to apologize because I
feel like I was aggressive in the
beginning of the show yeah and I
apologize I feel like there's a bad
energy between us right now are you good
I'm fine too let's move on okay good
what did you say ma'am I can't hear her
oh oh dude can you hug and make up they
want a hug I guess you know
yeah
yeah
foreign
Bobby give him a hug
Bobby Bobby oh no no no no no
[Applause]
I I like that he kept the mask on for
safety
also the fact that Bobby really doesn't
do the road that often makes us just
that much more special they haven't
announced that many dates for the tour
yet but it's set to begin February 17th
in Spokane Washington and continue on
the next night in Seattle 2023 is coming
in hot the already garbage boys have
announced plans for New Year's Day live
show beginning on January 1st and so far
it seems like it might be similar to the
Matt and Shane live show just in the
sense that they're filming it at a venue
in front of a live audience however it's
different than that show because they're
also teasing some segments that they
filmed beforehand including some
interviews with their mothers Patty and
Denise who are commonly referenced on
the show it was like people the second
like athletes get their checks or
whatever it's like no one needs yeah ten
thousand dollars they've made it this
far without it like it's not going to
change their life they're just gonna
blow it you don't have to pay for things
for people you know with your money yeah
that's like they were like auditing
people the guys like yeah I pay for 348
cell phones right now you're like what
the [ __ ] it's just like [ __ ] 20 grand
a month and T-Mobile [ __ ] plans hear
that Patty you're cut off as of right
now
um do you eat your pizza crust
yeah okay the show will be streaming
live on moment house starting January
1st at 7 pm right now tickets are just
12 closer to 15 after fees actually but
it seems like they're putting a lot of
work into this one so I'm excited to see
how it turns out guest spots from last
week your mom's house did not have a
guest two bears one cave was Bert and
kumal nanjani no Tom whiskey Ginger had
on Reggie Watts kill Tony tonight is
with Brian Simpson Dan Soder was on
stavy's world and flagrant talked with
drewski now there's a hole in my pants
but it was like in this area you know
like but who is that none of you guys
are fat I'm not saying like a fat thing
that's kind of like you're not fat yeah
you guys aren't in like you carry it
well a fat thing in what way like
explain like no let's address what he
just said
I wait till we're on today
[Laughter]
I'm sorry did you think you were yeah
you might as well say I'm thick though
yeah that's okay you can call yourself I
don't care it in the front but I got
that [ __ ] in the back that's what he
said
[Laughter]
this past weekend in theavonne talked
with young gravy Stavros was on The Joe
Rogan Experience we might be drunk out
on Natasha Leggero the Honeydew had on
Rich Voss Tom Papa was a guest in are
you garbage and the tigerbelly had on
preach as far as new stand-up specials
go that are either out right now or
coming out very soon there's a few
exciting ones starting off with Andrew
Santino cheeseburger that's named the
cheeseburger his name of his new special
that's gonna be on Netflix starting on
January 10th pretty excited for that one
also Sam Morrell put 14 bonus minutes
from his last special same time tomorrow
his specials on Netflix but he put the
bonus minutes on YouTube so check that
out if you like the same time tomorrow
you get 14 minutes of bonus from Sam
Morrell that's a loud Jack what is that
jacket
a flare a floral guy
buddy gave me and I like it your buddy
gave you a
that's an interesting friendship
dude I got you something
what is it it's a it's a jacket with
flowers on it
do you want to [ __ ] me dude I don't
understand
that does it for this week's joke World
comedy update as always thank you so
much for watching this video and we'll
be back again next week with some more
comedy news I'm debating changing these
news updates to Tuesdays instead of
Mondays just because of the timing of it
all sometimes by the time we're done
recording editing finding the news doing
the thumbnail all this [ __ ] it's like
either midnight
on Monday or it just has to be posted on
Tuesday anyway so I feel like it'd be
more consistent if it was on Tuesdays
but it's a better start to the week if
it's on Mondays that's what I'm debating
right now I feel like it's still early
enough to change it it's only episode
30. this is episode 30. that's like nine
months of the joke World comedy news
that's pretty cool thank you guys for
sticking around for nine months uh Go
download this episode on Spotify or
apple wherever you listen to podcasts to
support the show for some reason
downloads is the only metric that
matters in podcasting I don't know why
but that's how it is so download it uh
like this video comment you know do all
the YouTube stuff too you know I'm
asking a lot but
I don't know it doesn't seem that hard I
like and comment on these videos and
download them on Spotify I'm doing it
and I'm making the video so you don't
even I'm not even asking you to make the
video I'm just asking you to interact
with it if you think about it it's
selfish for you to watch this whole
video and not like and comment and
download so
look yourself in the mirror
buster
[Music]
thank you
[Music]